what is happening there citizens of the
reject Nation we are going to watch
today from Pixar the teaser trailer for
the film Elemental and of course joining
me today's co-host John how are you John
I'm feeling animated how are you sir I'm
feeling animated too ladies and
Gentlemen please go ahead and leave a
like that helps us out in the algorithm
and also go ahead and subscribe and
click that notification Bell also
because uh got some reactions to some
movies coming up a Decor line that's
going up tomorrow gonna be shooting with
a return against Sarah Erickson for the
movie disenchanted and then there's some
other ones in the works that you might
be surprised I haven't seen yet but hey
just keep a lookout for that alrighty
let's see what the elemental trailer is
all about
the 27th Pixar movie
so they can't die now
element City
[Music]
hi
oh it's got like that Soul animation
Earth people water people
air people fire people
the universes have to be connected I
mean come on look at this yeah that's
cool
[Music]
no
oh
[Music]
I like that
that's about good visual comedy
go ahead and Breakers
oh
oh you're dangerous to be around sorry
Amber
[Music]
to meet you Wade and Ember
[Music]
opposites react
oh wow wow wow well that looks beautiful
John what are your first thoughts yeah
it looked really gorgeous and a very
easy way to introduce us to what this
new world is gonna be like what if the
different elements of our natural world
had feelings yeah um but yeah I mean I
loved just this little Glimpse at the
design at the world at the different
people and character designs and whatnot
uh yeah the animation looks really
beautiful really stylized certainly but
also just so tangible with the textures
and especially when you're looking
through the water when you're looking at
the Flames uh the Earth's characters
with the plant you know life and all
that stuff is uh it's quite beautiful
and I think you're on to something there
with like the being that this seems to
be another faculty of just the existence
of the natural world it's got to be
happening somewhere in a similar plane
to stuff like uh you know soul and maybe
even inside out what did you think yeah
I feel like that all those theories
about connecting to the fix our universe
I've got to be true to some extent
because I'm looking at the animation I'm
like yeah this seems very reminiscent of
other films that have come before it
within the Pixar Camp I'm about to
confess something to you guys I've only
kind of seen inside out what happened is
without saying anything that'll get me
in trouble with YouTube Community
guidelines it is I hate a certain
something ah that
um 20 minutes in I've passed out and uh
I don't remember what I saw he took a
melatonin that's yeah we'll say that
what that's called yeah yeah yeah so I'm
like when people talk about inside out
it's usually a lot of nodding my head
yep I'm like I have no idea what
happened
so yeah that's one of the movies I want
to react to without eating anything
prior but uh yeah looking this up on
Disney Wiki uh the synopsis for this is
in a city where fire water land and air
residents live together her a fiery
young woman and a go with the flow guy
who I'm imagining is that water guy Wade
are about to discover something
Elemental how much they actually have in
common oh snap is that like inside out I
imagine
um I mean something about emotions
it's more like you have a character
experiencing things and then you zap
inside their head to see what all their
different uh spectrum of emotions are
doing to control don't go too far here
it's okay this is by the director of the
good dinosaurs you're in for something
totally I have seen the good dinosaur
and I actually enjoyed that movie I feel
like that movie's not appreciated enough
but yeah I mean I feel like this will be
one of those movies I will probably have
I'm not familiar with these actors uh
Leia Lewis and I know I'm pronouncing it
wrong namadu mamodu athi I'm not
familiar with them but it's cool to get
you know an animated movie where the
voice actors are not like super famous
celebrities you know I'm sure they have
work that probably some of you guys are
very much familiar with I'm personally
not but usually it looks like they try
to slap on like really famous names in
there that everyone knows and I like
that they're just relying on the Pixar
name for this and with the idea of
exploring elements I feel like this is
kind of a that's it's a common property
exploration they've done before like oh
these characters represent elements and
what do those what are those
personalities and even though a lot of
the time they can feel like they are
opposing but finding out the
similarities and how they kind of
necessitate each other in terms of
balance and also that you can't really
exist without the other I like the idea
of exploring that through this animated
medium that is the glory of Pixar so I
imagine that like many of these great
Pixar movies that there'll probably be a
lot of funny moments in there that
they'll probably be some just yeah
absolutely adventurous sweeping times
but perhaps get emotional and then you
know I like I like when Pixar goes a
little bit ethereal I like when they go
into this dreamlike realm you know Seoul
was my favorite movie of the year that
it came out and I'm enjoying what I'm
seeing so far I'm curious to see what
kind of the musical influences are
because I got a little bit of like into
the spider-verse fives for some reason
when she goes onto the train and puts
the headphones on because clearly
there's there's something about her
being fire that seems like she can't
just be herself like she has to be
hidden like there's there's this the the
sense that I was getting is that she's
not accepting of herself just because of
the fact that she has to remain hidden
and seems a little bit Meek even though
she can be like explosive and dangerous
and kind of like a Rogue X-Men situation
well yeah I wonder if maybe that's a
thing for the fire people of this world
in general yes maybe you're you know
more prone than any of the other
elements to Accidental destruction or or
lashing out in ways you didn't maybe
intend to and I bet there will be a
personal journey to be learned from that
and I'm sure that you know Wade will
probably need to learn maybe to conduct
the flow and not just go with the flow
true yeah they could learn from each
other absolutely opposites react this
year 2023. Democrats versus Republicans
let's get it going guys alrighty well
what did you guys think of this
Elemental trailer leave your thoughts
down below uh go ahead subscribe click
that Bell leave a like last but not
least let's send this with a patreon
it's only fitting that we shout out
Everett pixel might Baker might
considering that this is a movie made of
pixels here that's right um but Everett
looking at your patreon account it seems
that you have been here for 51 months
you have been baking that pledge like 12
times 4 is 48 so yeah four four years in
three months that's a good amount of
time man it's almost ready it's hot and
gooey that pledge thank you so much for
being here for for like that that is a
commitment so
um I really really appreciate it we both
do and I want you to have a happy
holiday season and I hope that you're
able to spend time with loved ones and
family and you know friends whoever may
be pets the internet you know go on some
sites pay to you some things I don't
really know what you got to do to make
yourself feel good but do whatever it
takes to feel good because you deserve
it thank you friend we'll talk with you
soon
[Music]